This is not casinos, champagne,
and Aston martins.
It's not James Bond.
Wait, what do we do?
Well try not to get caught
for as long as you can.
My money is on
about thirty minutes.
The Slow Horses are a
real bunch of misfits.
And they were all at
one time working at MI5.
And the thing that they
have in common is that
they have effed up.
I didn’t mean to kill him!
Of course you didn’t, If you meant
to kill him, he’d still be alive.
They park them in an
old building far far far away
from Regents Park,
where the center of MI5 is.
You probably know how many people
have made it back from slough house.
None.
All these people want is to get
back working for the Top Dogs.
Come See This. Hostage.
He’s being held here.
There is something finally
happening here.
What's it got to do with you?
Whatever going on will be
a job for the real agents.
When this kidnapping happens, and
there's more to it than meets the eye,
you really find out that these misfits
really actually come together
as a team and they're
not actually so useless.
I could murder a coffee.
Whats the canteen like in this gaff.
The leader of the Slow Horses
is Jackson Lamb.
I don’t know what
i’m looking for.
The remnants of a
once promising career.
He’s rude and obnoxious
to everyone around him
but he was a great agent
and incredibly smart.
Working with you has been the lowest
point in a disappointing career.
That twist and that flippancy.
I kinda like that side to it the
precariousness of it is part of the fun.
And watching Gary work.
The mans a genius. He’s
a proper stage actor.
Which is why he’s got
his feet in the ground.
Right, so what do we do then?
What we always do here.
Absolutely nothing. Come on.
We have a lot of spy dramas.
And I think this one is unique.
You can’t really fit it
into a particular genre.
Slow Horses is
really good writing.
Theres lots of
twists and turns.
Not just in the story,
but in the characters.
This is going to be
something really special.
This is something that
I haven’t seen before.
It's everything that you would want,
action, humor, espionage.
All in like the perfect mix.
You people are slow.
Bringing you up to speed is like
trying to explain Norway to a dog.
This is gonna be
just a killer show.
She’s covering her tracks,
but it's the covering of the tracks that
always gets you in the end.